I'm absolutely bullish on China this
year in the sense that they have greater
ability to continue to stimulate their
economy and maintain political
stabilities of consequence in pretty
much any country in the world investors
should care about the Chinese economy
less about the Chinese stock market when
they start pulling shenanigans like this
it erodes confidence in their future
growth which is the most important
question for investors this year I think
that the next thing that will happen is
that all the asset markets like the
Titanic will crash it won't matter very
much whether you own a big castle or the
SNB
China is slowing but it is not
collapsing I want to underscore that
china is not collapsing it's still
growing at a decent rate the envy of
much about the rest of the world if we
have Ryan Groth like little great like
China
forget about the equity market what's
really should concern investors around
the world is the currency because what
China has been doing is not only
weakening its daily fix but it has been
losing control of the offshore market
and that is really significant